you know something that I something that
I talk about a lot is the fake wives and
I want to start talking about archetypes
of fake wives because a lot of times
women come in and say I am the authority
on marriage I have been married 10 I
mean I'm not going to say names but I've
been married 10 20 30 40 years now the
40-year marriages tend to be a bit more
legit but let's look at the 10 20 25
year marriages okay let's look at those
um and what I what I call these are
really the wives in sheep's clothing
these women don't believe in being a
wife they're not submissive like a wife
is supposed to be and they they've
typically lived a very feminist
lifestyle but claim trap even though
it's very clear to the outside world
that they are not